LUKE CHURCH: Hello, everyone.
Glad you're get
back from the break.
And I don't actually know
why we're talking and not
just listening to
how to make alcohol.
But you know, either way works.
I'm Luke Church.
I'm a user experience
researcher.
And apparently, I'm
also a coffee mug.
DEVON CAREW: Hi.
I'm Devon Carew.
I'm an engineer
on the Dart team.
LUKE CHURCH: And so what we're
going to talk to you today
about is about how to
build production Dart
apps with an open source
workflow-- nice, long title.
What that actually
means is how it
is that you can use services
that other people have built
to make your lives easier.
And we're going to use DartPad,
an application we built,
as an example.
So what is DartPad?
DartPad is a place
that you can go
to write little snippets
of Dart in a browser.
And frankly, if
you don't actually
want to listen to us
talk, just hit that URL
and have fun for the
next half an hour.
That'll be great.
So we built this for
a couple of reasons.
It's really important
for the Dart ecosystem
to have a place where people can
write little snippets of code.
They can try
something out that's
independent from their
production workflows.
And you can write
little snippets of code,
share them with other
people, as a way
of explaining Dart to people.
So this just makes the
ecosystem work better.
It makes it a little
more efficient.
The point to stress today is
that everything you see here,
you can do at home.
So we're not using any
special magic here-- well,
maybe just a little.
But it's all built
out of services
that you can build to build
your production apps today.
So very briefly, DartPad
is split in two parts.
There's a user interface.
That comes from
the DartPad repo.
And there is a Dart
services library.
That runs on App Engine.
And it provides things
like compilation,
code completion, analysis.
And we split it up
this way so you can
use either of these two bits.
So if you want to
build your own DartPad,
you don't need any of our UI.
You can just use these services.
You can also connect the
UI to something else.
So what we're going
to talk about today
is how we made sure
that this actually
works and is actually fast.
So the agenda, lots of stuff.
We're going to
cover all of these.
And I'll start off by
handing over to Devon to talk
about continuous integration.
DEVON CAREW: OK.
So let's say you
start a project.
You already have
a bunch of code.
You have some unit
tests written,
a couple of developers,
and maybe you
plan to get pull
requests in the future.
You want to get some rigor
around this workflow.
And the way you
want to do that is
using continuous integration.
So it's basically a system--
I'm sure that many of you
are familiar-- but it
automatically runs your tests,
builds your app, and does it
automatically on every commit,
so that you have
very good visibility
into whether the code
you're committing
is functioning-- either
you or your team members.
There are a couple
of good systems
to use, continuous integration
systems for a Dart app.
Travis CI recently
got Dart support.
Drone.io has had Dart support
for a number of years.
And if you're interested
in getting visibility
into your Windows
testing, AppVeyor
has an easy system for
getting Dart support.
We're using Travis on DartPad.
So I'll talk a little bit about
getting it set up with Travis.
You just a tiny metadata file
in the root of your project
to basically tell
Travis that you
want to use the Dart runtime
when you run your tests
and give it a point or two,
the script that will actually
run your tests.
And those scripts typically
do a couple of things,
like analyze your
Dart source code
to look for errors
and warnings, fail
the build, if there are any,
and run your unit tests.
So here's what it looks
like, a typical build.
So we got a pull request
into the DartPad UI.
It shows you the build
output live, in real time.
It tells you whether the
build passed or failed
and notifies you by email.
Here's our build history
from a few weeks ago.
So you get to see again,
like each pull request,
you get a green
light, red light.
And just to validate
using it, these
are the results as of a
week or two ago for DartPad
where the UI project had about
200 pull requests, 400 builds,
and 30 failures.
And the service
back-end had about 100
PRs and, again, failures.
And the good thing about
getting those failures
is those all happen
in pull requests,
so you get visibility in that.
And every time we
merged code to master,
we knew that it was working.
So our master always
stayed clean and shipable.
Next, we're going
to talk about--
and what we had running
initially on Travis
was our unit tests.
So Luke is going to
talk a little bit
about some functional testing,
another type of testing.
LUKE CHURCH: Sure.
So functional testing-- well,
why would we want to do it?
So I heard a rumor
on the internet
that not all browsers
behave exactly the same.
I mean, it might be news
to a lot of folks here.
But you can see a
browser not quite
behaving as we would expect
on the screen in front of you
here.
A person trying
to use this isn't
going to have a good
day with DartPad.
And noticeably,
they can't actually
write code [INAUDIBLE].
So it's really useful to be
able to know that ahead of time
and to be able to have a
way in which we can verify
the behavior that we're
handing to all of our users,
independently of which
platform they're running on,
in a way that doesn't
result in us having
to do that testing manually,
one browser at a time.
So we've been using a
service called Sauce Labs.
A few others you could use
is BrowserStack, as well,
to do this.
And what Sauce Labs enables
you to do is two things.
One is that you can spin
up, from a large collection
that they offer you, an
arbitrary environment.
And you can play with your
website in that arbitrary
environment in a manual way.
So what you can see
here is me checking
that the basic
functionality of DartPad
works in Internet Explorer,
without me having to go and get
a Windows machine.
This is really useful.
So that gives us the
ability to quickly test
on a number of
different platforms.
You can also,
however, add things
that do automated verification.
So if you add this
piece of script
here to one of the test
libraries, what this is doing
is spinning up a web
browser, reading off
the title of that web
browser, and verifying
that the cycle is as expected.
So we can write this
once, test it locally,
verify that it's working
on our platform, and then,
via the magic of Sauce Labs,
have it scale out to test
and run across all of our
target deployments in one go.
So this is how we're ensuring
that the product that we're
shipping to users across the
browser platforms we care about
is behaving as we would
expect, as we add features.
DEVON CAREW: Awesome.
So that was functional testing.
And I'm going to talk a little
bit about code coverage now.
So why is code coverage good?
So we have a green light, red
light for our build right now.
And that's awesome.
But we don't really
know how much we
can rely on that green light.
What is it really telling us?
So for that, we get a little
bit better information if we add
code coverage to the process.
So that tells us really how
much of our code is being tested
and if we can really rely on a
green build when that happens.
So how?
So we're using a
Dart package called
dart_coveralls in
a hosted service
called coveralls.io to
get our code coverage
information on each build,
on each pull request.
It's a simple setup.
Basically, this dart_coveralls
package runs your unit tests,
uses the Observatory protocol
to collect coverage, formats
in a way that coveralls
likes, and uploads it
to coveralls with the
commit information.
We can take a look at
what that looks like.
So this is our
site on coveralls.
And this is, again,
each pull request.
We have visibility
into the coverage
and whether it's
increasing or decreasing.
You can dig into the
results for a pull request
and see, file by
file, your coverage,
which ones are well covered,
and which ones maybe
aren't as well.
And into a file, you
can see line by line.
So we can see that this method
that actually should have
had coverage-- and we
probably expected it
to have been tested-- wasn't
actually being tested at all.
And something
important to remember.
We had a very nice
measurement there, 81%.
It's nice to have more coverage,
but you shouldn't really
be chasing a specific number.
You want to go
for quality tests.
LUKE CHURCH: It's a bit higher
than 80 now, though, I think.
DEVON CAREW: 87.
Yeah.
But we're not chasing a number.
LUKE CHURCH: No.
Not in any way, whatsoever.
DEVON CAREW: But
basically, what it does ,
it gives you visibility
into how well it's tested.
So you may choose
not to add tests
for getters, and two
strings, and things
that really don't matter
or are going to fail
your test in the compiler.
But really, it gives you
visibility into things, maybe,
you thought were
tested, that aren't.
Or I could get a pull
request from Luke
with some great
back-end services that
really decreases the coverage.
And I could say, why don't
we add some tests to that?
LUKE CHURCH: Yeah, but
that would never happen.
DEVON CAREW: And just to
jump back to coveralls,
it does have some nice
trigger notifications.
If your coverage drops
below a certain amount
or drops a certain
amount in a pull request,
you can get proactive
notifications about that.
LUKE CHURCH: Yep.
DEVON CAREW: And I'll
hand it back to Luke.
He can talk about web
hosting and scaling.
LUKE CHURCH: OK.
So the position you're in now,
looking through this list,
is that you've
written some code.
You've written
unit tests for it.
system tests for it.
And you have some sense of
how much of your application
is being tested by your
various test suites.
That's great.
So now, the question is how do
you actually get that to users
so they can do things with it?
So we use App Engine to do this.
We actually split the
project into two parts.
As I mentioned earlier,
one of the ideals
here was that the
Dart services should
be usable by people who don't
really want any of our UI.
They should be able to use
it as a standalone component.
So we split App
Engine accordingly.
So we actually serve
static files-- CSS, HTML,
compiled JavaScript-- to
users from one instance.
And then we serve services
from another instance
that does analysis, completion,
compilation, quick fixes.
OK, so what that
does is gives you
an application that
runs in a web browser
and does the right
thing, so hosting.
And the way in which
we handle the services
is using the RPC package
that's been written.
So we get a request
in, via something
that looks like api/v1/analyze.
The Dart on App Engine
routes that to a Managed VM.
The RPC package then allows us
to select one of the endpoints
that we use for providing those
services, compute the results,
then hand it back.
This is all nice and well.
However, we're
running a compiler
and a bunch of developer
services in a browser.
It is really, really
important that that is fast.
So what you see here
is what it would
look like if we hadn't thought
about scaling whatsoever.
So you can see the blue line
is an increasing level of QPS
being sent to the
compiler endpoint.
And the red line is the latency.
And the big, scary
red lines are cases
where we would have
handed back HTTP 503.
Sorry.
Come back later.
We're broken.
This is clearly
completely unacceptable.
And so we've put
in a bunch of work
to making sure that, A,
the system is robust;
B, it scales; and
C, it remains fast.
So there's a couple
of things that we've
done to make that
work on App Engine.
The first one is memcaches.
So it turns out that
what generally happens
with something like
DartPad is someone
writes a small piece
of code, then shares it
with a bunch of other
people who also try
and to run that code
in their browser.
That code is exactly the same
as it was the first time,
so the compiler will
give you the same result.
So consequently, rather
than re-computing it,
we store that in a
memcache and just
immediately hand
back the results.
That cuts the compiler
latency down to, essentially,
the network latency.
And to give you an
impression of how effective
that is, we get memcache
hits on between 88% and 90%
of our requests.
That cuts a huge loading
out to the services.
The second really
important property
here is that you have to keep
the virtual machines warm.
So you have to reuse
as much of that state
as possible, whilst also
maintaining integrity
between your user sessions, so
you're not leaking information.
And we do that in
a couple of ways.
One is by hanging onto
a bunch of objects.
And the other is, as
we'll talk about later,
we use an uptime
service that sends us
a continuous trickle of requests
at a fairly low grade, which
keeps the virtual machines hot.
And so what's the
effect of that?
I mean, we heard a
talk earlier talking
about 50th and 90th percentiles.
So typically, from the
server point of view,
we can return an analysis in
an average of 16 milliseconds
and the 98th percentile.
So the people who are
having a bad, bad day
are at 54 milliseconds
for analysis.
We're currently looking at
ways of shrinking that a bit.
But that's the kind of numbers
that we can talk about,
which means that,
when you use DartPad,
it should feel pretty much
instant for a lot of cases.
Compilation is a
bit slower, again,
but you're still looking
at a fairly reasonable--
even for the 98th
percentile, you're
looking at it taking 2.9
seconds to compile and hand you
the results back.
Again, looking at ways
of shrinking that a bit,
but it's still within a
reasonable performance
for feeling fast.
And you can compare that
to the previous graph
where, if you don't care about
scaling and latency at all,
your compile times
are up into the 40,
50 seconds when things
start going wrong.
And the thing that
we'll see later on
is that these are useful
numbers to understand.
They're numbers to understand
for the actual server
performance whilst
we're doing compilation.
But what we really care about
is end user-facing latency.
And our average compilation
latency is 650 milliseconds.
That's partially due to an
addition from the network
traffic.
And it's partially due
to, as we were saying,
memcache taking out
90% of the queries.
So that's how we get code
to users fairly quickly.
Devon's now going to
talk about how we make
sure that we keep it quick.
DEVON CAREW: Yeah.
So I'm going to talk about
some hosted metric services.
So we've done some work
to make the back-end fast.
We have benchmarks running
on each commit and tuned
the back-end.
We've actually done some work to
make the front-end fast, which
basically means we don't
serve up many bits.
There are as few
bits as possible.
And we make as few requests
as possible when we start up.
So we use dev tools to
optimize our loading.
We're compiling our
JavaScript minified.
And that's great.
So we're fast, but generally,
things won't stay fast.
Your code's going to bit rot.
And unless you actually
watch the back-end
and the front-end performance,
your speed's going to degrade.
So how do you keep it fast?
You want to measure
it, basically.
On every commit, you want
to measure your performance
metrics.
And we're using a hosted
metric service called Librato.
There's some other
services out there like it.
But you can basically
post your metrics
on a build to this
service, and go to it
and view your graphs
of the metrics
over time, which can
actually be very powerful.
So this is how
you get it set up.
There's a Librato library
where it's just basically
a simple HTTP post of
arbitrary metrics data.
In this example, we're
measuring the size
of our compiled desktop
front-end and mobile front-end
and uploading those.
And here's what it looks
like at the Librato site.
You can see we have
over a dozen metrics--
the front-end size, our
back-end benchmarking times
in terms of times to compile,
times for code completion,
times for analysis,
and an actual benchmark
from a few weeks ago.
Our compiled desktop size, you
can see, we ran at about 350K
for our compiled size, except
we had a huge spike there
when it jumped to almost 700K.
What happened there was
we imported the library,
which transiently imported
lots of other Dart code,
and our front-end size doubled.
But having a service
like this lets
us track these significant
regressions very quickly
and identify the get
commit that caused it.
But it also helps with
a lot more subtle things
where, over a month, maybe
your size increases by 10%,
and you can identify
two or three commits
that each added 2% or 3%.
So having visibility into these
regressions is very powerful.
So Luke is going to talk
about uptime monitoring
to round this out.
LUKE CHURCH: So what
you're in a position now
is that you have
your application.
You're shipping it.
It's working.
You know that you're
not regressing code size
as you go forward.
This leads to another question
suitable for keeping web
maintenance people up at night.
If your site goes
down, how is it
that you would know that
you're no longer serving
to your users, you're now
just throwing error messages
at them?
And in order to
find this out, you
can use uptime
monitoring services.
So we're using a service
called Pingdom, [INAUDIBLE].
We've used a couple of different
ones-- [? Status Care ?],
for example.
So what these things
allow you to do
is request that the
service sends you
a continuous series of data
points-- roughly speaking,
I think, in this
case, we configure
it as to one per
minute-- saying,
OK, perform this
code completion.
Do this compilation.
Do this analysis.
And it allows you to track both
any times when you get outages,
you can get proactive
notifications, SMSes, emails.
It also allows you track any
creeping latency problems,
or any latency problems
if you get a report in of,
your site was really slow.
Understanding whether that was
slow because of the services
or slow because of networking
issues is really useful.
So we use uptime
services to do this.
It also, as I
mentioned earlier, it
sends this low-grade,
continuous trickle of requests
into your system, which,
if you tune carefully,
means that the frequently hit
paths will be warm whenever
a new series of users turn up.
So you get that continuous
keeping the system productive.
So that gives us
basically a summary of how
do you build an application, how
do you make sure it's reliable
as you're building it, how
do you ship it to users,
and then how do you
make sure that it's
keeping working
and keeping serving
your users with the
experience that you want to.
So over to Devon to wrap up.
DEVON CAREW: Cool.
Yeah.
So I think a takeaway
from this talk,
hopefully, is that
Dart works today
with a number of
hosted services.
These services can be really
valuable for your projects.
If you want to see examples of
how we actually hooked up these
services to continuous
integration and other systems,
you can look at
the DartPad repo--
github.com/dart-lang/dar-pad.
And we'd like to take
a moment to thank
some of our open
source contributors
who've had some significant
contributions in terms
of our code completion UI
and some other functionality
from external people.
And one other thing to announce.
We're shipping 1.0
today of DartPart.
So go use it.
[APPLAUSE]
LUKE CHURCH: There were
some DJs around somewhere,
weren't there?
Where did they go?
DEVON CAREW: So unless
they tell us otherwise,
I think we have
time for questions.
No microphones, so-- nope?
OK.
LUKE CHURCH: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Do you guys have a
roadmap for the near-future?
LUKE CHURCH: So the question
is, just off the record,
do we have a roadmap
for the near future?
Yeah, we should
add some features.
That would be good, wouldn't it?
[LAUGHTER]
I think we planned
a bit of a UI redux.
There's some stuff on
mobile that we'd like
to make a little bit better.
That would be great.
DEVON CAREW: Yeah.
We support sharing today,
using GitHub gists.
It uses an anonymous API, which
means you can create a gist.
But if you update it, you
have to fork an existing gist.
So we're going to add some OAuth
authentication to it so you can
update any gist that you
create or fork other people's.
And yeah, we're going
to do, probably,
a UI redux of the
desktop and the mobile.
They're two separate
applications right now,
two completely separate UIs.
And we want to unify that,
probably around a material
design look and feel.
LUKE CHURCH: Yep.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LUKE CHURCH: I'm also kind
of interested in whatever
it takes to get people to learn
a new programming language.
It's kind of a
research interest.
So looking at what we can
do around smart suggestions.
So we already have a bit of
a documentation discovery
support.
But I think, because it's more
intended for small snippets,
we can probably
do things that are
quite a lot smarter than that.
So looking at putting some
of those experiments in,
seeing which ones
work, it's on the plan.
AUDIENCE: Are there any
plans to make an embeddable,
little, just try it out thing?
Like if I have a
blog and [INAUDIBLE]?
LUKE CHURCH: Sure.
So the question
is, are there any
plans to make it embeddable?
So if you just want to try a
little bit out in your blog,
could you do that?
I think it's certainly
something that we're
very interested in doing.
One of the reasons to split
the strategy up this way
was to mean that, if you wanted
a completely different UI
for doing that, all the
services are available for you.
But yeah, we're kind of
interested in doing that ,
particularly around [? Doc's ?]
discovery on API [INAUDIBLE].
We'll see how that plays out.
MALE SPEAKER: I can be
your question buddy,
if you guys want.
DEVON CAREW: OK.
LUKE CHURCH: Sure.
MALE SPEAKER: Are
there more questions?
I just killed your vibe.
I'm sorry.
LUKE CHURCH: All right.
Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: We have
time for more, right?
We have a couple--
LUKE CHURCH: I have no idea.
There's no clock here.
I have no idea how long
I've been going on for.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
you've got time
for a couple more questions,
if you guys-- yes?
No?
Questions, anyone?
Yes, let me bring you a mic.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Any plans on adding
collaboration feature?
Two guys could code together.
DEVON CAREW: Oh, collaboration.
So the question is, do we
have any plans for adding
collaborative editing?
Yeah.
It's not on our roadmap.
I think it'd be an
interesting use case.
But yeah, DartPad
serves a good purpose
right now of learning
Dart on the web
and being able share snippets.
And collaborative
is interesting,
but it's definitely
not something
we're actively working on.
MALE SPEAKER: The code
is open source, though?
DEVON CAREW: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Can you add
auto-complete to Google Docs,
and then just call it done?
DEVON CAREW: Yeah.
Yeah.
LUKE CHURCH: Yeah, although
collaboration for source code
is really hard.
There's a lot of very
complex workflows
that people engage in.
But it would be fantastic, if
somebody else felt like trying
that out as an experiment.
MALE SPEAKER: Any more?
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
that you run benchmarks
on every commit,
which is something
our team should definitely do.
I was wondering what
frameworks and services
you use to do that.
DEVON CAREW: Yeah, there's
a benchmark harness package,
which we were using for a while.
It's available on GitHub.
It supports
synchronous benchmarks,
which is great, unless you
need to return a future.
So we basically have a
small internal version
of that, which warms up whatever
code you need to benchmark.
Warms it up for a while,
then it runs like 10 of them,
divides that number.
So you can actually see the
benchmark on our GitHub repo.
But its benchmark harness
is obviously pretty tiny.
You just want to do it
right, and then-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: So does that
run with Travis UI,
and then post the
result somewhere?
DEVON CAREW: Yeah.
So our build script on Travis
basically analyzes the Dart
code, looks for errors and
warnings, runs our unit tests,
runs the integration
tests via Sauce Labs.
Everything looks good.
It gathers code
coverage information,
and ships it up to Librato.
And it also runs the
benchmarks and ships that.
Well, it ships the benchmarks
to Librato and code coverage
to coverall.
So yeah, our benchmark
script is like 40 lines long,
and does a bunch
of-- or our build
script does a bunch of things.
So yeah.
LUKE CHURCH: We also run
separate, out of band,
much more intensive
testing before publishing
each new major revision
of Dart services.
We run a large collection of
basically all of the Dart line
suite of tests over it.
But that takes multiple
tens of hours to run,
so we don't run that
on every commit.
AUDIENCE: How long does
their CI take right now?
MALE SPEAKER: The question
was, how long does the CI take?
LUKE CHURCH: It's like
a few minutes, isn't it?
DEVON CAREW: Yeah.
I think used to know more,
but it's like three or four.
It turns around pretty quickly.
So yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: So as
usual, the default thing
that I say at the end is,
these guys will be around
and would love to have you come
talk to them, if you see them,
if you have more
follow-up questions.
LUKE CHURCH: Absolutely.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks, guys.
LUKE CHURCH: Thank you.
DEVON CAREW: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]